you
but for arrest space adventuring is
tiring work
we've reached hrs - 1084 captain it's
emitting a very weak dog this little did
as normal if they're ecstatic battery
levels before initiating an extended
sanitization session
let's give these little fellas a wide
berth captain
captain I've been attempting to contact
you with urgent news
however communicational functionality
was impaired due to the power outage a
UTL vessel has been tracking our
position and just recently docked with
the station they are patching into the
station's transmission lines now I
cannot stop I've been waiting for this
day since we tagged your ship and
Cascadia captain so glad we finally have
this opportunity my ship is docked with
1084 there's no escape
I think not
the refueling system I Cascadia is
landing pad larger Shiva you've been
poking your nose into restricted
locations this
sublight ah I hate him
don't apologize squad I'm ordering a
recall my dad used to say words have
power he approved him true
good news customer all germs and
contaminants have been neutralized
muting volume now
step lively captain
Oh
you
[Music]
job done we can go home to the ship
right reducing a diffuse hold on a tick
don't we know short reign from Cascadia
you
please would you kindly inform the crew
that long chats with ADA are not
required every time the captain leaves
the ship
we've arrived at the grammar breaker
what's occupying your brain tubes today
Sam
finally a base of our own soon we'll
have eyes on every corner of the system
well done captain I'll have those
dismantled you can never be too careful
when moving into someone else's
territory aside from the automated
security did you meet any resistance at
the station I knew it
they've been shadowing us since monarch
maybe even longer I've been less than
honest with you your assignments weren't
strictly about the salvage business you
might have figured that out already